So I don't really
understand young people.
Like, I know I am one technically speaking,
or I'm meant to be at least,
but I've always felt like I identify
more with sleepy old men
than I do with the
"youth" of today.
And this isn't all
young people,
but your stereotypical
18- to 25-year-old,
who goes to lots of parties and has a lot of fun
and says the word YOLO a lot,
I find them
very confusing.
However, back in October, I found
myself doing one of those things
that crazy
young people do,
and I went on a road trip
around Europe
with a bunch of fun loving YouTube
kids because, you know what,
you do only
live once. SIGH
The whole trip was organized and paid for
by the overly nice people of Contiki,
who are a "youth" oriented
travel company.
They planned out
every activity for us,
even down to like what
food we were eating,
which, as a self confessed
control freak, was pretty terrifying.
And one of those things that Contiki
decided for us was our "morning song,"
which was one song that Contiki played
at us every single morning of the trip
when we got
on our coach.
And the song that they picked, naturally,
was "We Are Young" by Fun.,
a song all about being young
and getting drunk
and having a nice time
and setting the night on fire,
which sounds incredibly
dangerous to me.
Let's just say that it's not a
song I can identify with,
nor is it a song that I ever thought
I would know all the lyrics to, but I now do.
The plan was to visit five
different countries in ten days,
so we were
packing a lot in,
and we started in Munich, Germany
around the time of Oktoberfest,
which is the
world's largest fair.
What I found about Germany
is that there is a lot of meat,
there is a lot of potatoes,
and there is a lot of beer.
and Oktoberfest, specifically,
is a temporary Disneyland, basically,
but specifically for beer,
and I don't drink, surprisingly,
so naturally I was a bit skeptical
of the whole thing,
especially of the giant beer tents
filled to the brim with drunk people.
I was surprised to find,
though, that the rowdiness
that I tend to associate with
large amounts of drinking here in the UK
just wasn't really there.
Everyone was just
sort of nice and jolly.
Our second stop on
the trip was Austria,
which became an instant favorite of mine
just because of how relaxing it was.
It was beautiful and quiet,
and we had this really nice lunch
outside a cabin on a mountainside,
and we went on a
bike ride in the afternoon
and then we went
white water rafting,
which was a
bit different.
It was very wet and
very, very cold,
and not something that I ever would
have decided to do of my own accord,
and was also the most fun
that I had on the entire trip,
which I was
not expecting.
Honestly, I was just amazed
by how pleased I was
that someone else had forced me to do
that because it was just the best thing.
Country number
three was Italy.
We stopped off
quickly in Verona,
which is the setting of
"Romeo and Juliet,"
where they have a Juliet's
balcony and a statue of Juliet,
where the tradition for some reason is
that you go up to her and you rub her breast.
So, I did that, obviously.
And then we went
to Venice in Italy,
which was a very weird place to visit
because it's a sinking city,
and nobody really
lives there.
It's very eerily quiet.
But it was also really
weird for me because
even though I had never
been to Venice before,
I had this really strange sense of déjà vu
walking around the square
because some of Assassin's Creed Brotherhood
is set in Venice, the video game.
And so I walked around thinking,
"I've climbed to the top of that tower,"
and "I think I've killed a
man in that museum."
The next place was
Paris in France,
which greeted us with a
lovely amount of rain.
We went up the Eiffel Tower even though
it was too foggy to really see anything.
We went to a cabare show
in the evening
and then, we tried some
snail because, you know,
that's just what
you do in Paris.
I don't understand
the appeal.
And our final stop on the trip was
London, England, which is here.
That's-- That's where
I am right now.
We ended our trip in our own
dedicated pod on the London Eye,
and just as our little ride
was coming to an end,
everybody around me
started singing.
♪Tonight♪ Yah!
♪We are young♪
And once again,
I found myself surprised
because I gave in and
I sung along with them,
and not only that,
but I actually enjoyed myself,
and I don't really know how
I feel about it yet, to be honest.
Contiki's slogan is
"No regrets,"
which has never been a phrase that
I've really liked because, to me,
it only seems one step away from
that kind of YOLO attitude of,
"Let's make the same mistakes
over and over again
because we don't want to have to think
about the consequences of our actions."
But I found myself realizing
that "No regrets"
needn't be used as an
excuse to do stupid things.
It's there as a motivator
to do those things
that you're not sure if
you'll enjoy or not yet
because you just
haven't tried them,
and so, although by the end of this trip I was
so exhausted and so happy to be home,
I didn't regret going
on it in the slightest.
There you go.
There's my cheesy ending.
Sorry. Sorry that
I grew as person. Ugh.
STEPHEN FRY VOICE: You've just had the almost
imponderable joy of watching charlieissocoollike,
which makes you, like, cool.
RAINING